طبعا الجمعيات السريه سواء في منطقتنا في
الشرق الاوسط وحتى في العالم الجمعيات
السريه الامريكيه والاوروبيه العراقيه
والعنصريه كانت الانترنت هي بوابه الحياه
بالنسبه لها لانه الجمعيه السريه كان
غرضها في ترويج افكاره هو ان تجد منبر غير
مراقب ويمكن الوصول من خلاله الى جماهير
الداخليه التابعي او العامه لنشر الفكره
الاخوان المسلمين بشكل عام كانوا من اوائل
من استثمر في في هذه المجال نذكر قصه
سلسبيل شركه الحاسبات الشهيره في القاهره
في الثمانينات خيرات الشاطئ نعم
فكانوا مجتهدرين اوائل وبداوا باشام
مؤسسات لانشاء بدات ثوره
السيديز والاشياء هذه الاشياء الموسوعات
والكتب وما الى ذلك نعم الخليج كان هو
الممول
الرئيسي ولذلك تلاحظ الاخوان في بعض
الخليج تحريدا السعوديه والكويت وقطر هي
الحنفيه التي لا تنقطع والثراء الذي من
خلاله تاسست تنظيم الدوله في العالم هو
خلال هذه الاموال التي استثمرت فيها قضايا
افغانستان وفلسطين وغيره وكان في حتى في
ادبياتهم يبررون لانفسهم اخذ قسط من هذه
من هذه الاموال واعاده استثمار وقصه يوسف
ندى والاستثمارات العالميه التي همم في
سويسرا وغيرها من دول العالم واضحه ومن
خلال هذا المال دخلوا والانترنت وهذه وهذا
شيء عجيب الانترنت هي الوسيله الوحيده
التي لم تقاوم من الحركه الاسلاميه بشكل
عام ومن الاخوان التحرير بالعكس يعني هو
من التليفزيون والاذاعه ومعظم مسائل
الاعلام بالتردد همم وحتى في بدايات جماعه
الاخوان كان لديهم موقف منها من هذه
الاشياء واستخداماتها وحتى كلمه حزب لم
تستخدم لعام 2011 حزب الحريه والعداله كان
لديهم مواقف ثابته بحكم انه هذه الاشياء
غربيه قد تدخل الاسره المسلم لكن هذه
الوسيط الذي اصبح وسيط شخصيا بين هذه
التنظيمات واتباعها استقبل بترحاب واستثمر
فيه يعني موقع جديد مجله الدعوه حينما
حجبت كان اول موقع تقريبا جل عام 98 في من
هذا النوع ثم انشاوا على مدى الاعوام يعني
2000 و2003 و2005 يواكبون التقنيه عائشه
او المنتديات من 2001 و2002 ثم انشئوا
اخوان اون لاين عام 2003 وانشئوا اخوان
ويكي كم
محرك بحث خاص بالاخوان الاخوان سيرش ثم
ايضا اخوان تيوب واخوان بوك على وزن
يوتيوب وفيسبوك وهذه ايضا تعود الى الفكره
المفصليه التي همم التي اثرت كثيرا وتؤثر
على مسيره الاخوان هم يرون انفسهم وما
لديهم انهم البديل لكل شيء هم البديل
للسلطه عالم موازي نعم هو البديل المنهج
والبديل للاعلام في مرحله الاعلام
الاسلاميه
لكن ان ترى ان كل شيء في اتفق عليها هذا
المجتمع انه خطا وان لديك البريد حتى وصل
الى الطب الاسلامي كل هذه الاشياء هي
محاوله
لانهم في عز الشعريه ولا شعوريه في
المجتمعات كوكبهم الخاصه يعيشون في هذه
الاسر والدروس بوعيا النقيب والرئيس مكتب
الاداري وما ذلك من خلال نشرات داخليه
كونوا عالم طبعا هناك سر لابد ان يعلم
لماذا هذا الاصرار في عصر المعلومات
المتفجره اثرت كثيرا على فكره الاخوان على
فكره يعني الاخوان التابعين اتكلم عن
العشرات الالاف ومئات الالاف التابعين في
القرى والنجوع والبلدات البعيده اصبحت
المعلومات متاحه وايضا
ظهر ايضا من من من الاشياء التي اثرت
عكسنا على هذه الجماعات وغيرها ان حينما
تفاضح اللصوص همم سواء في مراحل معينه
اصبح ينشرون مذكراتهم واقعهم سواء باسماء
شخصيه او باسماء مستعاره فظهرت كثير من
الحقائق
والعصر المعلومات واكبر كاشف واكبر فاضح
للجمعيات